>>Roman Nurik: All right.
We are good.
I think we are ready to go.
Thank you everyone for coming to our session,
Android Design for UI Developers.
Today we are going to talk about how to implement
some of those awesome patterns that we have
documented on developer.android.com/design.
My name is Roman Nurik.
I'm on the Android developer relations team.
>>Nick Butcher: Hi, my name is Nick Butcher,
also on the Android developer relations team.
We focus on UX and design to help you guys
build awesome applications.
Some of you might know us from Android design
in action, our weekly YouTube show every Tuesday
on YouTube where we talk about how to design
awesome Android applications.
So today's going to be slightly different.
We will be focusing much more on the code.
This is a developer conference.
We will talk about building the cool applications
not just design them.
>>Roman Nurik: We will cover three main themes
today.
First is app navigation where we will talk
about some of the newer patterns as well as
some of the existing navigation patterns that
are out there.
Then Nick will talk.
>>Nick Butcher: I'm going to tell you all
about responsive design.
What it is, why you should care and how you
can go about building it in your apps.
>>Roman Nurik: If you pay attention, if you
guys are on your laptops, if you pay attention
to a single section of this session, please
listen to Nick.
So whenever he talks, listen to him.
>>Nick Butcher: No pressure.
>>Roman Nurik: I will finish off with a discussion
of the Holo visual language specifically how
to implement some of the visual characteristics
that are a part of Holo style and theme.
So first let's talk about app navigation,
shall we?
So anytime we talk about navigation you think
about a couple of different ways to navigate.
So one of those important ways is lateral
navigation.
Basically the way this which you switch between
sibling elements or kind of members of a single
collection or a top-level sections in the
app.
So the action bar, as probably many of you
know, is one mechanism or one tool that gives
you access to lateral navigation.
So you can use things like tabs or a spinner
in the action bar to provide kind of access
to sibling sections.
We're not going to talk about how to implement
the action bar.
We have a good training class on developer.android.com/training
that talks about how to do this.
Implementing effective navigation.
Implementing lateral navigation.
Please take a look, it's really awesome.
We do want to talk about compatibility for
the action bar.
So as many of you know, the action bar is
not available on versions of platform below
API 11.
But we have been working on something called
ActionBarCompat will give you access to the
action bar and all versions 2.1 and above.
The native APIs here, you have activity, fragment
activity, get action bar.
The APIs for action bar compat will be similar.
The overall structure of the code doesn't
change.
You swap different imports, swap in different
names for classes and things and you're done.
So this is not available right now, I should
mention.
This is still something that we're working
on.
It's going to be available very soon.
If you're using the I/O app right now.
It is using the action bar compat library.
It is coming sooner rather than later.
Like I said, it will be available on Android
2.1 and above.
You will be able to use it on those versions
which is basically all devices out there.
And a very important note here is that if
you are already using ActionBarSherlock, there's
a phenomenal library by Jake Wharton.
You shouldn't feel like you should switch
over to this version of the compatibility
library.
This is a phenomenal library.
It's going to be very similar in terms of
APIs and so ActionBarCompat we recommend for
new apps.
If you are creating a new app, consider ActionBarCompat.
Basically what this means, if you are thinking
about the action bar, not using it because
of compatibility, you no longer have that
excuse.
>>Nick Butcher: No excuses now.
Just use it.
>>Roman Nurik: Exactly.
Another component is ViewPager.
We talk about lateral navigation.
We also think about swiping left and right
or the swipe views pattern.
Now, ViewPager is kind of the conical implementation
of that pattern.
It's covered very well in our training classes
so we're not going to go into too much detail
there.
The reason I mention it here, we should really
be using it if you are using any sort of horizontal
paging or built this kind of conical implementation.
>>Nick Butcher: Whenever you see tabs, think
swipe.
>>Roman Nurik: Exactly.
We do want to cover a new pattern that was
just formalized yesterday in an update to
the Android design guide called navigation
drawers.
So navigation drawers are for main navigation.
If you have disparate sections in your app,
navigation drawers is another tool you have
for navigation.
I'm not going to talk about all the guidelines
here.
All the documentation is published.
If you click on the navigation drawer section,
you will see all that stuff.
I will say that -- as many of you saw in the
Google Play music part of the keynote, the
navigation drawer has a slightly different
style than you'd expect.
It doesn't slide the content out of the way.
The action bar stays fixed.
Not sliding the content out of the way is
one way to further indicate that this is really
a piece of the app's chrome.
It's a piece of chrome like the action bar
that sits atop of your content.
So the content is stable there.
The other thing that this does is it helps
preserve the horizontal gesture space.
So if your content involves things like swiping
to dismiss and things like that, it's still
very compatible with this pattern.
>>Nick Butcher: In contrast to what you were
saying about action bar, if you are using
some of the other community libraries out
there, you might consider moving to this official
library because this implements all of our
best practices and UX that we recommend you
use.
So really do consider that.
>>Roman Nurik: Exactly.
I want to show you a quick video of what this
looks like.
The activity content, you press on the left,
bezel, it peaks for a bit.
You can interact with it, of course.
Then you can also kind of swipe to hide it.
You can also touch on the action bar's top
left area to show and hide it as well.
So there are a lot of kind of unique little
things about this, this pattern, and we're
going to talk about how to implement this
pattern using some of the new features in
the support library just released yesterday.
So to implement a navigation drawer, the very
first thing you do is in your activity content
you replace the top level layer with a DrawerLayout.
It works on API 4 and above.
Which is basically every device out there.
This DrawerLayout contains two children -- should
contain two children.
The first is the actual activity content.
So everything that you had in your activity
before.
And then the second child of the DrawerLayout
should be the actual drawer that slides out
and that's usually going to be something like
a ListView or a GridView or something.
Generally a ListView.
Now, you can set the width of this to fix
that width to whatever you want.
We recommend somewhere between 240dp and 320dp
of width.
You can vary that, of course, by device if
you find on larger screen devices you want
a slightly larger drawer.
Now, that gets you -- just doing that gets
you all the edge swipe stuff.
It does a lot of things for you.
But another important part of the drawer is
how it interacts with the action bar.
So for that we have another component that's
part of the support library r13 called ActionBarDrawerToggle.
That's basically kind of a helper method or
helper class that ties the action bar with
the drawer.
So you simply create a new -- substantiate
the ActionBarDrawerToggle.
Give it the activity.
Give it the drawer layout itself.
You give it the icon to show on the top left
because that icon is custom for navigation
drawers and then you basically set this action
bar drawer toggle instance as the DrawerListener
for the DrawerLayout.
Now, one quick note about the icon.
It's available for download.
We have both Holo light and Holo dark variations
and all the densities available for download.
You should customize this.
Changing the colors and such, make sure you
customize this to fit in with the theme.
One other important -- I guess, very important
part of the action bar drawer toggle is that
you need to pass through the onOptionsItemSelected
method from your activity.
This takes care of actually handling button
presses on the action bar's top left area.
Basically it just handles the android.R.id.home
click.
That's basically it for navigation drawers.
That's really all the main code that you need.
It's really easy to do.
You guys should absolutely start using it
if it makes sense for your app.
Again, this is all available in the support
library r13 which was pushed yesterday.
So one last note, I guess, on navigation is
up navigation.
So we had a talk -- full talk dedicated to
up and back navigation last year from Adam
Powell and Rich Fulcher last year.
This year we wanted to give you tips and tricks
for up.
The first thing to do to implement up is tell
the action bar to show the up button.
You can do that by using this method here.
Now, Jelly Bean, as of Android 4.1, you can
automatically -- or the system will automatically
handle up presses for you.
You simply give a parent activity name for
each of your activities and the system will
take care of taking you to the right place
when you press up.
For earlier versions of the platform, you
can use this meta data element to supply that
same value.
That's worth noting that in a lot of cases
you have to customize where you go when the
user presses up.
Rather than handling all the up stuff yourself,
simply override these two methods.
You override the getParentActivityIntent method
to tell the platform which activity to visit
when you press up.
You can also customize what happens by providing
extras that you would then handle in that
activity.
Then you can also override the onCreateNavigateUpTaskStack
method to basically customize what happens
when you are navigating up outside of your
core task.
So this happens, for example, if you get to
your app from something like gmail.
Pressing up should stay within your app.
This let's you customize what happens there.
You'll see that it still mirrors the overall
structure of your app, how you got to that
activity.
So I think that's it for navigation.
I'm going to go off and hand things to Nick
to talk about responsive design.
>>Nick Butcher: Thanks, Roman.
Part of the joy and strength of the Android
is the variety of devices.
Small phones, big phones, tablets, everything
in between.
As developers that can perhaps seem daunting
to make sure your UI is going to look great
on those different sized devices.
So luckily Android has been built from the
very beginning to deal with this kind of difference
sized devices.
So it has lots of greats tricks in there.
RelativeLayout and layout weights and so forth
will help to you build a scalable UI.
I hope that you are using all these things
already.
The problem with this is that scaling your
UI up and down is only going to get you so
far.
I will outline issues you may run into if
you are relying on scaling techniques and
how you can better work around them.
So one of the challenges you might encounter
if you are scaling is something like this
where you have excessively wide layout.
Here we are running text and images to the
entire width of the device and it produces
quite an uncomfortable reading experience
which is hard to scan.
Ideally, aim for line length of 45 to 75 characters.
Anything longer is going to feel very uncomfortable
and not easy to use.
We don't have great tooling for automatically
detecting line lengths.
But you can use the multi-config editor which
will help you to get an idea and visually
inspect what your layouts is going to look
like on a variety of different devices.
One hint that you might look for that you
run into in this issue is whenever you find
yourself typing this, like layout_width="match_parent",
stop and think how is this going to scale
up to larger devices?
Is this going to lead to this excessively
long line length issue?
Another challenge to run into is something
like this, where you end up with a very unbalanced
kind of UI.
So here in this example application.
We can see all of the content is kind of,
like, clustered together tightly into the
top left-hand corner leaving a huge space
around.
You can encounter this behavior if you are
using a list-driven application.
And you end up with this huge amount of white
space on the other side on larger devices.
What you really want to ideally go for is
a more balanced look.
You want to be able to step back and squint
at your application and have an overall balance
distribution of your content.
A missed opportunity is the last one.
When your app is running on a larger device,
you want to take advantage that you have this
extra room, extra space.
Put your content first, really enjoy it.
Here's an example of an application which
is perhaps showing a lot of imagery.
The images come out very small and you can't
see them very well.
Such a shame that you are not actually reacting
to the amount of space available on the device
and showing them off.
So those are some of the challenges you might
get into in scaling approaches.
Here are strategies.
The first strategy is combination.
This is where you have more space available
to you on a device.
You combine different content.
On a phone or smaller device, you have two
layouts which you combine together when you
have sufficient room.
Building this kind of layout is easier if
you are already embracing fragments.
Fragments have been pretty well covered.
I will not take you through them.
They are building blocks to reduce your app
down to so it makes it easier to define individual
blocks and lay them out differently.
You only have to code them once and then move
them around.
To build this kind of master detail, you can
use this trick alternate layouts.
All of those activities includes a single
fragment filling up the whole screen.
On larger devices, we override that same activity
and include both fragments at once.
I'm using the layout-w resource qualifier.
Devices that have 600dps of width, pick up
this configuration instead.
Easier than writing all that, is using this
template.
Use this code to create a master detail flow.
Work through the wizard.
Give it to your objects.
It will generate the activity.
It is getting much easier to create this kind
of layout.
>>Roman Nurik: It's worth noting this isn't
currently available in Android studio, Tor
would be able to tell us.
It is not available but it is something we
are going to work on to get it in there.
This is an important tool.
>>Nick Butcher: And another tool for building
these combination approaches is another custom
layout that has just launched in r13 of the
support library, just went out yesterday.
That's a SlidingPaneLayout.
The SlidingPaneLayout that you use to build
these two-column views.
You see this is my master; this is my detailed
pane.
If there's enough room it, will lay them out
next to each other.
If there isn't, like the case on the right,
it will overlap so one is on top of each other.
Sliding the finger across will reveal them,
the master pane again, and you can click or
slide back to go to overlapping view.
It is worth calling out differences to how
this is different than the DrawLayout.
These two panes really are in the same plane.
So unlike the navigation draw where chrome
comes across the top, these are content panes.
They move together so you can think of them
as being very tightly connected.
>>Roman Nurik: To summarize it is to say that
drawer layout is for primary app navigation.
Really kind of chrome versus content.
This is all about content.
This is effectively a tool to take master
detail flows and simplify them across different
orientations and tablets.
>>Nick Butcher: Awesome.
To implement this SlidingPaneLayout, you define
it as root layout and give it two children.
The first child is going to form that master
or left-hand pane and the second child is
going to be the content pane.
So you define a layout width for each of those
and if the sum of those two widths exceeds
the amount of space available on the device,
they will overlap and you have this sliding
behavior.
If the device has enough room, it will show
them side by side.
You can also set a layout weight of one on
the content pane which means it will expand
to fill the extra space like when it is shown
on its own.
You can really think of the content pane's
layout_width as the minimum size.
This is an easy way to build a responsive
layout.
So that was it for combination-type strategies.
The next strategy to go on to is what we call
macro reflow.
The idea of this reflow is to rearrange the
major blocks of your content.
So here is an example where we can see when
shown on a larger device in landscape we reflow
it down to rearrange the content blocks to
avoid those problems of having really excessive
line lanes or unbalanced content.
Here you can see by using fragments, we just
defined the content once and very simply just
using a different layout, just specifies an
orientation.
When it is landscape, they will be stacked
next to each other.
When they are in portrait, they will be stacked
on top of each other.
Really simple but makes a huge difference.
So the next strategy to know is what we are
calling micro reflow.
So rather than taking these major blocks and
moving them around, it is actually going to
look at the individual blocks and change representation
depending on how much space they have to layout.
So this kind of micro reflow makes huge use
of what we call dimension files.
Hopefully a lot of you are using these already.
I want to stress it in case anyone isn't.
This approach makes huge use of dimension
files, so I hope a lot of you are using these.
Just like in your layouts, I hope none of
you are hard coding strings into your layouts.
The same is true for your layout configurations
and your sizing and dimensions and so forth.
You really want to be putting all of those
things into a dimensions file or a style for
two reasons.
Firstly, it let's you reuse these same dimensions
across different screens throughout your app
so you can have consistent margins and consistent
text sizing throughout your application.
And secondly, it let's you override them and
provide alternative sizes and dimensions on
different sized devices.
In this example we've defined standard dimensions
for text sizes and margins and line spacing,
for example.
Define them in this dimensions file and use
them throughout the application's' different
screens.
And then on a larger device, you can provide
different sizes so it's really simple to use
the same layout but bump up the text sizing
and other margin sizes or line spacing to
get a better experience on a larger device.
>>Roman Nurik: This helps recompose your screens
on larger devices to rebalance.
When you step away and you squint and you
look at the screen, you kind of see everything
smooshed to the top left.
This type of approach will really help rebalance
things.
It's very, very important to use this technique
especially for tablet UIs.
>>Nick Butcher: One point to especially call
out here.
In this example, I'm using the SW or smallest
width qualifier.
What this does is looks at smallest width
of the device which is the width in portrait.
It just uses that.
So it's an orientation agnostic qualifier.
The reason I've chosen to use this here is
some of these dimensions, you don't want them
altered just because you rotated a device.
It can jarring to change text size when you
rotate your device as it will re-layout so
also chaninging text size could cause confusion.
Using something like SW, orientation agnostic
qualifier, you can keep dimensions stable
while some dimensions will change.
So some examples of doing this kind of micro
reflow is margin point.
Sometimes you can't use combination or reflow
to move around or show more content on the
screeb but you still want to avoid unbalanced
or excessively long line lengths.
Instead, you can simply introduce page margins.
So a technique for doing this is setting a
style onto your content container here called
MarginPoint.
We will use that style to provide the layout
width of the content container.
On a smaller device, the style is going to
say match the parent here.
It's going to grow up until you reach max
much size you want the content to reach, here
we're using 600dps.
When it reaches that size, it will clamp and
never continue to grow any larger.
Also by setting a layout gravity of center,
it will put the content in the center and
have these margin points so you don't get
this excessively wide or unbalanced feel.
>>Roman Nurik: Two quick points.
The w600dp modifier, qualifier, if you will,
so it's important to note that that is the
width of the screen and not the width of the
content.
So if your content has extra padding or margins
or such, make sure to account for that when
you are doing the math to determine the switching
point.
Another point I wanted to make is that this
might not work for every scenario.
It's perfectly okay in some cases to use dialogs
on tablets and full screen activities on phones,
phone size UIs.
The way to do that is to use the Theme.Holo.DialogWhenLarge
theme.
Customize that using a similar resource qualifier
based approach.
>>Nick Butcher: So the last point to give
you on doing this kind of micro reflow approach
is switching from lists to grids.
So as I mentioned before, ListViews can feel
unbalanced when they grow to larger devices.
It's going to be great to switch over to a
grid representation that you have content
that works for it.
Something that has a consistent height or
has a very visual kind of graphic which you
can include, this can work really, really
well.
So to build this kind of approach, instead
of using a ListView, you simply use a GridView
in the layout.
You then use an integer resource for the number
of columns attribute.
You can then define the number of columns
it will show based on the size of the device.
By default, going into single column which
will give you the ListView representation.
On larger devices, step up to two or more
columns.
You simply need to respect that change in
your adapter.
So in your adapter, you can query that very
same integer resource and find out how many
columns the GridView wants to use and inflate
a different layout for the individual item
so it can be a list style item in a single
column or grid style layout in multiple column
view.
>>Roman Nurik: GridView and ListView are very
similar in terms of API.
They both inherit -- they both sub class the
AbsListView class.
So switching between ListView and GridView
on different cases, that's also possible as
well.
So definitely feel free to do that in your
apps.
>>Nick Butcher: Cool.
Those are some of the challenges you might
encounter with a scalable approach and how
responsive design can help to you get around
them.
And one point I wanted to make, in all of
those kind of strategies we just talked through,
never once did we talk about a phone layout
and tablet layout.
Each of them was based upon the content; it
took a content-first approach.
So by defining your content on, you know,
these switching points, instead of thinking
in like strict device terms you kind of future
proof yourself a little bit.
Who knows whatever size and shape or orientation
aspect ratio device is going to come around
the corner, and you want your application
to be able to cope with them.
By putting you content first and thinking
about your content to size it, whatever device
comes along we'll just pick the most appropriate
one that's going to work for it.
So now I'll hand it back to Roman to give
you pro-tips on implementing the Holo visual
language.
>>Roman Nurik: So holo visual language, that
means a couple of different things.
Just for some really quick exposition or I
guess background, I guess, back in Android
3.0, Honeycomb, we redesigned or rethought
the UI for Android and that kind of manifested
in this Holo visual language.
And there are two major tenets that I can
think of right now about the Holo visual language
that are important to note as we go through
the process of implementing it.
The first is a refocus on content versus chrome,
so we want to spend as many of the pixels
as we have available to us on content rather
than showing boxes and borders and things
like the chrome.
It's kind of like a refocus on showing the
information rather than the machinery behind
it that makes everything work.
The second tenet, I guess it's a sub-tenet
of the first one, is really a focus on space
and typography to communicate hierarchy rather
than things like borders and boxes and so
on.
So as we go through this process, keep that
in mind because that's kind of what influences
some of these decisions.
So the very first thing you need to do to
implement Holo, use the Holo visual language
in your app, is to inherit the Theme.Holo
theme or one of its descendents.
So one thing to note is this is only available
on API 11 and higher, Android 3.0 and higher,
so one thing you can do to mitigate that is
to have this kind of switching behavior for
the base theme.
You can inherit Theme.Holo.Light, for example,
on API 11 or higher and then just Theme.Light,
which is available everywhere in other versions
of the platform.
>>Nick Butcher: This trick of actually having
a base, like a level of indirection between
the inherited theme from the base theme, which
has like a different switching point is really
handy because some of the platform behaviors
which you want to take advantage of may have
been introduced in different API levels and
using this base theme behavior lets you insert
them into your hierarchy.
It's really handy.
>>Roman Nurik: We use this a lot in the I/O
app which will be open sourced at some point
very soon so you can see how we make use of
this.
I do want to mention that when we release
the ActionBarCompat library it will handle
a lot of this stuff for you for your activities
theme or your applications theme.
Simply you would inherit Theme.Appcompat.Light,
but the file name might change.
Rather than switch on this you can just inherit
on this.
This is again coming soon.
So once you've inherited the Theme.Holo theme
-- we should figure out a better way to say
that.
Once you've inherited that theme it's time
to use some of the resources that the framework
gives you for free.
And one of the favorite things that you like
to say, Nick, is lean on the framework.
Use what it gives you for free so you don't
have to reimplement all of this stuff from
scratch.
>>Nick Butcher: There's nothing worse than
trying to imitate the way the stock UI looks
because you might overlook a slight detail.
You can actually just reuse the same styles
that we used to build it and then you will
get the exact same consistent behavior.
I think I stole that saying from Rich Fulcher!
>>Roman Nurik: Exactly.
So one thing you will notice is that in the
next couple of screens, next couple of slides,
we're going to be using this question mark
android colon syntax, and that is basically
a theme attribute reference.
We're basically accessing something that is
stored in the theme, whether it be a dimension
file, like the listPreferredItemHeightSmall,
which is the standard item height for a small
list item, or a style resource for like loading
spinners.
So for example, to create a large loading
spinner or indeterminate -- indeterminate
progress view, you simply create a progress
bar and set its style to the question mark
Android progress bar style large attributes,
theme attribute.
And then if you want to use drawables, for
example, we have built in drawables into all
the themes so you can use the listChoiceIndicatorSingle
drawable as, for example, the drawableTop
attribute in a TextView or drawableLeft or
such.
So really you get a lot of stuff for free.
I definitely advise you guys to take a look
at the docs for the android.R.Attr Java class,
I guess.
It contains a whole bunch of these you can
use in your apps.
So I want to talk a little bit about that
space and typography stuff.
The first is space.
Take a look at this screen.
So I think there's kind of a fundamental problem
with this screen in that it's lacking visual
hierarchy, visual structure.
There's kind of just floating elements out
in this massive space that don't really have
any sort of hierarchy.
So one way in which we can fix this is to
introduce dividers.
So these dividers are basically just that,
they divide different sections of the screen.
It's really kind of using the minimal amount
of pixels possible to introduce hierarchy
rather than using boxes and borders and things.
To implement these dividers it's fairly simple.
You simply set the show dividers attribute
on a linear layout to middle to draw these
dividers in between the different children
of the linear layout, and then you provide
the drawable to draw in that space.
And as you can see here we provide -- the
system provides a standard drawable for that
space.
It's also, you know, worth noting that in
addition to using dividers to introduce hierarchy
you should still be using the standard 16
dp margins and the standard 48 dp visual rhythm
that we talk about in the design guide, and
that will really help establish a structure
and kind of like a rhythm to your screens.
So another thing I wanted to talk about with
dividers is divider padding.
So if you provide the divider padding attribute
here, it's eight dp's, it will actually draw
some space above and below or to the left
and right of the divider, and this really
helps introduce further hierarchy.
So in this case imagine that we didn't set
the divider padding on the dividers between
the text and the delete icon.
It would just look like a table.
It would just look like a grid of things and
it wouldn't be clear what the real hierarchy
was.
But as soon as we introduce the padding you
can immediately see that these are a set of
list items and within each list item there
are two separate touch targets.
So going along with this theme of refocusing
on content rather than chrome, we want to,
you know, also do that for buttons.
We don't want to keep drawing borders and
boxes around buttons because we can do that
in a different way.
So this borderless button style, which is
very commonly used with dividers, it really
helps kind of simplify your UI.
It really helps focus on the content over
the chrome.
So one thing to note is that it is borderless
so you do need dividers to set its kind of
boundaries, but when you touch the button,
you -- it does light up to indicate that this
is the touch region.
This is the thing you're acting on.
So to use them you simply create an image
button or a button and you set its style to
the borderlessButtonStyle theme attribute.
This gives it to you all for free.
Another type of -- another variation on borderless
buttons is a button bar, so if at the bottom
of a dialogue or bottom of a screen you have
two actions, you can use this button bar style
on your linear layout and it will automatically
create the dividers and apply the weights
correctly.
Actually, it doesn't apply the weights.
Never mind.
So it automatically adds these dividers, and
when using button bars, make sure that you
do the order of the buttons correctly.
The preferred button should always be on the
right, so save versus discard or delete versus
cancel.
Even if it's a negative action, like delete,
the preferred item should really be on the
right.
It's very important as of Android 4.0 and
above.
So use that button bar style and then each
of the buttons in that -- I've been saying
the word button way too much.
>>Nick Butcher: It's lost all meaning.
>>Roman Nurik: Yes.
Each of those buttons needs the buttonBarButtonStyle
to apply -- somebody needs to count how many
times I just said the word button.
It's like 20.
Anyway, it's very straightforward.
Again, this is very little code.
You're not really doing much.
You're just setting styles.
>>Nick Butcher: Lean on the framework, lean
on the framework.
>>Roman Nurik: Yes, take it away.
Again, it has that touch highlight.
Another thing to think about is how do you
provide this touch feedback on things that
aren't buttons, things that may have kind
of layout or a view hierarchy within them.
Reto touched on this in his session early
this morning.
I'm not going to cover it in detail, but really
using selectableItemBackground, which is a
drawable, it resolves to a drawable, using
that as the foreground or background on a
view is really kind of a great way to do that.
Also, if you're using a list you can use the
list selector attribute to provide the right
drawable to use there.
>>Nick Butcher: I can't stress how important
this touch feedback really is.
As you kind of pare back on the crutches and
the chrome, you need to communicate to the
user what is interactive and what does something.
Anything that is interactive really needs
to react visually react whenever you touch
it.
So using things like this can really communicate
that.
It also will communicate the bounds which
you can interact with.
So as you use the borderless buttons, without
using the bounding boxes, touching it will
highlight the entire interactive bounds so
the next time the user comes back to the element
they have already this model of where they
can interact and where they can't.
>>Roman Nurik: Exactly.
So another important visual element in the
holo visual language is list headings.
So list headings are basically the things
that separate different groups of list items,
and they should really be 14sp, bold, all
caps, just like action bar tabs, for example,
and they should have a 2 dp separator below
them.
So you don't really have to figure all this
stuff out, you can actually just use a listSeparatorTextViewStyle,
set that on the TextView and you automatically
get the styling.
If you do end up customizing this with your
brand's accent colors, then by all means use
those values.
This is kind of a great tool to use for releasing,
I guess, the space to the list, the content
itself in the list.
So we've been talking about space a lot.
I want to take a brief moment to talk about
typography, which is incredibly important
in the holo visual language, so as of Android
4.1 we've given you this really robust typographic
palette, I guess, for use in your apps.
So you can use new weights and variance of
Roboto to really help to communicate structure.
Rather than using text sizes to communicate
structure and hierarchy, using weights is
kind of a nice way to do that.
So a couple of quick notes don't use thin
for really small text.
It's best for large headings.
Also, light is best for headings as well.
And condensed can work really well for like
news article headings.
Light does work well in body text, but you
do need to be aware of kind of the minimum
sizes that you should be using.
>>Nick Butcher: As a rule you probably want
to be sticking to regular or light on slightly
larger type sizes and reserve thin and maybe
larger light for things you want to stand
out essentially by having larger size, but
lighter type looks really, really good.
>>Roman Nurik: So quick note, this is Android
4.1 and above.
If you want to use this in earlier versions
of the platform you can download these fonts
at Google Fonts and you can import them into
your project.
One last quick note, another important part
of the Holo visual language is again that
full-bleed images using as much space as you
can dedicated to content.
One of the things you run into sometimes is
not all photos come in the same aspect ratio
so what you can do is you can use an image
view.
You can use an image view with a consistent
aspect ratio and drop in an image, set the
scale type on the image view to center crop
to actually make sure that the image fits
nicely in the image view and doesn't kind
of mess with your layout.
So one thing to note here is that this does
end up cropping things in some cases.
You know, that's really good for -- it's fine
for things like bacon photos or meat or like
landscapes.
Not so good for like photos of people where
their eyes may be cut off.
It's kind of creepy.
So definitely the center crop technique is
very good for making sure that your UIs stay
nicely aligned and fit.
When using these full-bleed images, it's best
to kind of introduce separators between them.
Very light separators, maybe one dp or so,
to really make sure that colors of different
images don't bleed into each other.
So before -- that was a lot of stuff to cover
and obviously there's a lot more.
We can't cover everything, but the last thing
I want to cover is producing Holo assets.
So, you know, as we showed, you can use XML
and some minor styling stuff to really provide
a lot of the assets for your apps; however,
you do end up still needing things like icons
and -- and PNG files and so on, and there
are three really good tools for that.
The first is the Android asset studio which
will generate icons for action bars and notification
icons.
It will apply the right sizing, coloring and
opacity and so on.
The second is the action bar style generator
that assuming your theming your app with your
brand's accent colors, which you should be
doing, you simply drop in those accent colors
into this tool and it will generate automatically
all the different assets that you need for
the action bar, tab indicators, as well as
the selectable item background stuff.
It will automatically create these kind of
like accented, pressed and focused states.
>>Nick Butcher: And the right hierarchy so
you just drop into your project.
Super simple.
>>Roman Nurik: Right.
And lastly there's the Android holo colors
tool, which does the same exact thing for
like check boxes and buttons and things like
that.
Now, I really want to mention that Jeff and
Jerome who wrote these two tools are in the
developer sandbox, so if you have bugs to
report, go harass them.
They're really awesome guys.
If you want a demo, a live demo of what this
looks like, definitely check them out.
>>Nick Butcher: They're great tools.
Just use them.
>>Roman Nurik: There are no bugs remarkably.
I think that's it for our talk.
Thank you once again for coming.
I want to do a quick shoutout that we can't
take questions right now, but Nick and I both
will be in the Android platform office hours
where we'll be able to take questions.
I also want to mention that we have an Android
Design in Action Live design lab.
What is it, tomorrow at 2:00 p.m.?
So if you want to come and learn how to design
an app from scratch without using computer
tools, we're just going to be sketching and
wire framing, definitely go check it out at
2:00 p.m. tomorrow.
>>Nick Butcher: And for those of you remote
watching on the live stream and so forth,
then we're actually quite active on Google+,
so follow us on Google+ or join the Android
Designers community.
The Developers community is also good.
And join in the conversation on the hash tag
#ADiA and the #AndroidDesign tag.
And tune in to Android Design in Action every
week.
Thanks very much.
[ Applause ]